Mark: Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier
Mark: and welcome back to Portal 2 with Shodleech
Mark: also known as Patrick. Heyyy
Mark: How's it going? Patrick: Heyyyy
Mark: How's it going? How you doing?
Patrick: Doing good. Mark: Good. Okay.
Mark: So actually funny thing. Patrick: Going awesome. Mark: Th-When you pick this up
Mark: I noticed that the door didn't close
Mark: so we can just walk right through it and have a cuuuube
Mark: We're probably going to break the game!
Mark: Oh..nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Pbrffffffff Patrick: No wait, it's gonna disintegrate.
Mark: Alright. Fine then.
Mark: I thought we got something.
Mark: Smell of human fear. Patrick: Also known as Mark.
Mark: Hey! I'm not full of human fear, I'm actually brave
Mark: I've faced a lot of horror games... you have no idea.
Mark: Ok, so... we...
Mark: This is a conundrum.
Mark: euughhhh
Mark: That doesn't seem to help anybody.
Mark: Okay.... ?
Patrick: Do I need to hold any button down?
Mark: No, I don't think so just yet.
Mark: But what we do need Patrick: Am I supposed to stay over there?
Mark: Ummmm, nooo...?
Mark: I have no idea what to do yet so we're still figuring this out.
Mark: Okay. So the basic principle is that we
Mark: need to get up there. The both of us need to get up there
Mark: so there has to be Patrick: And we got a laser.
Mark: I need to find out what this button does.
Mark: Oh, that's what that button does! Okay, so...
Patrick: I think what's interesting is that there are
Patrick: so much ways to put your portal.
Patrick: They literally made a ton of white areas.
Mark: Yeah, there are just an enormous amount of white areas.
Mark: So there is a button over here that will release a
Mark: disintegration wall that allows us to jump down and
Mark: gain some momentum here.
Mark: And I can't even press my look button through it.
Mark: I can't even press my look button at all anymore.
Mark: Why is my look button broken? Patrick: And we have to get
Patrick: My look button doesn't work either.
Mark: What the hell? They're suppressing our look buttons.
Mark: That's so bullshit. Okay.
Patrick: And right here is where the laser is supposed to go.
Patrick: Hello. Mark:  Ok. So if you look down there, that button
Mark: the big red button
Mark: it releases the disintegration wall down there.
Mark: So, I need you to go down there and press that button.
Mark: Ok. Now, you can let go of the button because now
Mark: no matter what
Mark: so long as I keep this
Mark: you can jump through these without the portal disappearing
Mark: So now I'm gonna take, uh, uh, wait.
Mark: Lemme take your portal back here
Mark: Okay, this is good. Okay.
Mark: So now, um, get yourself back up
Mark: Like just create your red portal on the wall
Mark: beside you and then walk up.
Mark: Cuz you already have a portal up there.
Mark: Ok, so walk up. Ok.
Mark: So, now stand on the edge and be ready to jump down through it
Mark: Because I just put a portal here so that you can
Mark: launch yourself up there.
Mark:  So jump- Patrick: Alright so right here?
Mark: Yeah, jump whenever you're ready. Patrick: Alright.
Mark: Trust me, its cool.
Mark: Wee! Okay.
Mark: Alright, so there's no boxes up there,
Mark: even in the room where all the things are. Are there any boxes? Anything?
Patrick: No, the only way to get something is if we both press the button at the same time
Patrick: And it'll give us something - Mark: Y-Yeah, but what's in that room?
Mark: The white room with the, the robots, what's in there?
Patrick: That's another laser thing, I think.. There's something on the wall
Mark: That's a laser emitter, I believe... Okay, so...
Mark: We both need to get up there but the only problem is... That, I can't get up there by myself
Mark: That's the only real issue
Mark: There's no portal-able walls up there, right?
Patrick: None, unless I go through here and the robots can get to me
Mark: Nahh, we don't need that...
Mark: Ohh there's a button! Ohh, there's a button that drops a box right there! Ohh duh..
Patrick: Oh, there it goes... It's, they're going back and forth
Mark: Okay so... Patrick: you're going with one box Mark: so that's ok
Mark: Okay so you can get down now... Because now -
Patrick: Wait, does that mean we have to grab it mid-air?
Mark:  Yes we do! Patrick: oh boy. Mark: So what we need to do... Is we need to get you momentum
Mark: Cause pressing the big, red button there flattens out the, the portable, the movable portable thing
Mark: That launched you up
Mark: So, if you press the big, red button.. See how it makes it flat
Mark: So we just need to be able to get up there, from that
Mark: And we can do that, or, maybe, nahh that wouldn't be high enough...
Mark: No we need to do, no we need to do it this way
Mark: So
Mark: We need
Mark: Alright.. So, I need you. First off, I need you over here
Mark: To press this button
Mark: Actually, first off, I need to go place this portal. Okay, you stay there, stay there...
Mark: ok, so I need to place this there, so that needs to be there, ok, so, alright, so now...
Mark: yeah, ok, press the button and I'm gonna put my portal there again. Patrick: alright
Mark: ok so that portal's there, alright, so come back up here because you need to leave this place a different
Mark: way than you came from it. So instead of jumping through there, because I have to be on that
Mark: big red button before that happens. Or, more specifically, you have to be on that, no
Mark: that doesn't make se- that can't make sense, oh oh ah ok yes, um, oh no no wait wait, come back
Mark: ok, I know what to do. Ok. I, I understand what to do because to do this... Patrick: there's a jump pad here
Mark: no, I know exactly what to do. Ok. So, watch this. Alright, so I'm comin' back through there. Aright, so
Mark: press the big red button again
Patrick: ok
Patrick: big red button...press
Mark: ok, so I can just jump through here, like this, and I can go up here. And then you, you can get up on the
Mark: other platform and then just jump through my portals cause they won't go away
Mark: jump right through. You got it. And now we're both up here and now we can both press these buttons
Mark: so be careful. Alright. 3, 2, 1 boink
Mark: and we have another cube and this cube can be used to either... Patrick: divert the laser
Mark: yeah it will. Or, more specifically, can be used to get the other button right now. Patrick: that was fun
Mark: yeah so, get over to the other side and then you can jump through my portals again to grab that thing
Patrick: alright so same thing I did before? Mark: yeah but don't, yeah
Patrick: and then like put one down here and go through? Mark: yeah
Mark: yes, that will be totally acceptable
Mark: alright now just jump through my portal and you should be able to, eventually it'll coordinate...hopefully
Mark: there you go! Well, no, uh, uhhhhh
Mark: phlaboink
Mark: grab it, move, there we go, now you're a champion
Mark: ok so now we just need to angle this. So drop that box down, there's a little black square down there
Mark: drop it so it's pointing against the portal wall, yeah there we go, then just have it straight in there, drop it down
Mark: ok make a portal there where it's pointing, AHHHHHH!
Mark: ok, so when you come back, just, um, uh, hit the springboard on the right side when you come out
Mark: hit the springboard, then you'll pop right through
Mark: and then we can do this
Mark: ok, now put a portal down there, just without going down there, there we go. Ok. And now on the other side
Mark: over here, without falling down. You can put a portal wall right there
Mark: there we go! See! Yeah! Alright! Ok, so, this is good. So... Patrick: now, we've still got killer bots
Mark: we still do have that. That is a problem. So, we need to take this off of there, I can put this one there
Mark: ummm, let's see. So that needs to stay there
Mark: that is the main problem right now. So we need to get...ugh
Mark: ok. Patrick: love the pink heart
Mark: thank you. I worked very hard at it. So, we need to get in that room without dying
Mark: that's the hardest issue. Ok. So forget that laser for now. We, we'll come back to that laser
Mark: uh, get over to the other side again. And then jump through my portal to get up there, or actually no
Mark: we, we both need to get up there so just, uh, drop that, er, um...uh...go over to the other side again and
Mark: we're gonna both do this
Mark: ooohh woosh. Patrick: good luck. Mark: thank you
Mark: stay over there for just a hot second
Patrick: alright
Mark: ok, so...the interesting thing is...there are...huh
Mark: so there is a laser trap in there but that means we have to get the laser in there somehow and that is
Mark: really weird. Patrick: should I jump through your portal? Because if you go through there, yours is gonna disappear
Mark: see I can't get in that room unless I have a box blocking my way. That would work
Mark: oh no, the box would be destroyed as soon as it goes through there
Mark: huh. This will, I would die if I go through there. But, maybe only one of us needs to go through there
Mark: and get to the end. So come through my portal. Jump through and get up here with me
Mark: ok, so what's gonna happen here is I am going to protect you. I am going to sacrifice myself so that you
Mark: can get to those bastards, and take them out before they kill us both. Ok?
Patrick: ok. Mark: we're gonna flank up the left side, stand on the left side, you stay right behind me
Mark: I will take their bullets for you. Ok? Patrick: alright, yes. Mark: 3, 2, 1, AHHHHHHH
Patrick: AAHHHHH! Mark: AAHHHHHHHH!!!
Mark: ok. Patrick: are you on f- knock back. Mark: they do. Patrick: apparently. Mark: but, if I go on the left and
Mark: you go on the right, then we can make it through, we can do this. We can get past them. Let's just do this
Mark: again. Go press the button. We can do this. So this time, I'm gonna go on the left and then you're gonna go
Mark: around the right. Flank em both, we'll win this.
Patrick: sounds like a plan. Mark: actually, no, I'm gonna go wide right, ah shit I need to get over there
Mark: one second, uh, just let me, hang on. Hang on two seconds. So I'm gonna go wide on the left and then you
Mark: go wide around, no, I'm gonna go right, you go left, woof. Ugh. Anyway.
Patrick: now we got no portal down here. There we go. Mark: ssssssssshhhhh shhhhhh
Mark: shhhh
Patrick: alright, so, go through your portal, like the same way? Mark: yeah
Patrick: wait
Mark: well, come on (laughing). Patrick: not enough momentum. Mark: well of course not enough momentum
Mark: you did a thing different than the thing you've done every time. Did you really go like, huh maybe this one
Mark: is gonna work? Patrick: (laughing) I have no idea
Mark: wow, then I am so sad. Ok. So this time, I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go wide right, you flank right off the left
Mark: side. Get as close to the wall as you can. Patrick: which is it? Are you going left and I go right?
Mark: I'm going right, you go left. I know I made this very clear. Don't even pretend to be confused about my direction
Patrick: (laughing) ok. Mark: alright, so, I'm gonna go right. Are you ready? Get as close to the wall as possible
Mark: you need as much space... Ok... Alright just let them, let em go to sleep
Mark: ok, ready? Patrick: set
Mark: 3, 2, 1, AHHHHHH! Look at me, look at me, look at me, look at me, look at me, OHHH they didn't like that
Mark: oohhh, ow, ow, ow, ow... Patrick: take that
Mark: that almost worked. Because... Patrick: they went after me. Mark: I know. Patrick: because you went farther
Mark: I know but it's fine. Patrick: I was a distraction. Mark: I almost made it through, I almost made it through
Mark: we can do that because... Patrick: what were you planning, Mark? Trying to take me out first instead?
Mark: yeah, pretty much. And it almost worked. But we'll, we'll do it together this time. And by together I mean
Mark: you'll probably die. Ok, press the button again. We gotta get over there. Patrick: I expected that
Mark: alright. Patrick: I guess I'm officially known as the button presser
Mark: yes, that's good job you're doing pressing them buttons
Patrick: yeah. Mark: ok, so...
Patrick: it's ready for me to get up there? Mark: yeah, so as soon as you get up there, we're gonna press those
Mark: suckers like no tomorrow. Ok? Patrick: we're pretty much, I'm the one that's distracting for now?
Mark: whoever gets there first. Ready?
Mark: 3, 2, 1, AHHHHHH! AHHHHH! Ow. Ok that didn't work. Patrick: parkour move
Mark: they, they hit me first and then they immediately went to you. So they only gotta go against one of us first
Mark: 3, 2, 1, I'm goin', look at me, look at me, look at me, look at me, look at me
Mark: well don't go like, don't go the way I'm going. Don't go the way... Patrick: you said straight at them
Mark: yeah, but, obviously that wouldn't mean the same exact path I took cause you're gonna get hit by the
Mark: bullets that they're shooting at me. In all honesty, I have no idea if this is gonna work and frankly, I don't think it will
Mark: but, we're trying. Patrick: how 'bout if this is gonna be a problem, I be the distraction? Mark: ok
Mark: fine by me. Fine. Fine by me. Patrick: it seems to be clear that they like shooting me
Mark: they do indeed do that. Ok, so, I'm gonna count 3, 2, 1, you go, then I'll follow immediately after
Patrick: ok. Mark: alright. 3, 2, 1, go
Patrick: cover for me! Mark: they went for me, why? Ahh. AHHHH. Patrick: I have one other idea
Mark: yeah, what's up? Patrick: there's two white walls in there. One behind them and one on the left side
Patrick: I think we're supposed to have enough time to get through there before they kill us
Mark: I just had another idea. And I know, I know, I know what to do. Oh I know what to do. Oh I know. I made it to
Mark: the button. I made it to the button just before they killed me. And the button opens up the wall which means
Mark: that one of us can carry this through. Ok, let's get up there again. We need to get up there but I'm gonna
Mark: bring this block with us this time. You're going to run in there, straight for the button. You go for the button
Mark: nothing else. You hit that button. As soon as you hit it, I, as soon as you hit it, I go right through this with
Mark: this box. Ok? Make sense? Patrick: I have one last question. Mark: yeah, what's up?
Patrick: did you see that, is there a white wall on the left side that I can portal through before they kill me and then
Patrick: I can portal right behind them? Mark: damnit! God. Ok. Hang on. It's fine, it's fine. Uhhh, no
Mark: it, w-, that's actually farther than the button is. I, I know we can make it to the button, we cannot make it
Mark: to that. So, flip flop, go on the right side. Ok.
Mark: this way I can see. Let them settle. And then, on your go, just go for that button. 100% straight for that button
Patrick: 3, 2, 1
Mark: aw, so close, oh, no. Patrick: (sigh)
Mark: this is hard. Just try to skirt right around that corner as close as you can
Mark: go superfast
Mark: aw so close. Ok, that's not gonna work. Sprinting at em is not gonna work, the teamwork's not gonna work
Mark: there's gotta be another way. OH! Oh! OH MY GOD this was so simple
Mark: oh we were doing so ba-, oh my god. Look at this. Right there, right there.
Mark: oooohhh my god. Are they both dead? Patrick: yes. Mark: well there you go then, now you can go
Mark: through, oh man now we both need to g-, oh wow. That looks bad for me. Oh, that is so bad.
Patrick: (laughing) Mark: woooo, ok. Patrick: you think for you? It looks terrible for me too
Mark: well, I mean, I (mumbles)
Mark: ok, now I'm gonna go through
Mark: now, ok, schwoomp, ok. Now that you're up here, before you go through my portal, before you do
Mark: make sure that the laser is going to the right place. Ok, go through there and get on the button
Mark: ok, now I'm going to leave this here. Excuse me, pardon me, switch me spots. Alright, so, leave that
Mark: there. Wait, leave that, right there. Ok. So now that's there. Alright, so, yeah the main
Patrick: are you still seeing the bullet holes? Mark: yeah. The main problem was that, uh, the laser, ok, now...
Mark: you can go back down...and...uh...portal the laser where it needs to be
Patrick: I think you're supposed to place your portals inside there before you walk out while I'm still on the button
Mark: you're right. You're 100% right. Ok. But actually, yeah, this is super easy. Let me, let me do that
Mark: here, just walk through my portal there. Walk through my portal. Patrick: there
Mark: easy peasy, easy peasy. Ok. Now that you're up there, I can just put this one here and then put the other
Mark: portal right there, and we got it! Yeah! Patrick: finally! Mark: yes! Oh man, oh there's more!
Mark: there's more?! Oh my god. Patrick: there's more? Mark: ok, we don't have time for more
Mark: we're all out of time for now. But, so, this is the last episode that I'm gonna be recording of Portal 2
Mark: with Patrick unless you guys really want more, let me know down in the comments below and be sure to
Mark: check out his channel. Shodleech is his name. Any final words Patrick?
Patrick: had a great time with Mark playing this, so if you do want to, shout it out. Mark: yeah, definately
Mark: but anyway, best of luck to you on your channel. Thank you everybody for watching out there
Mark: and as always, we will see you in the next video. Buh-bye! Patrick: Buh-bye!
Mark: don't ever interrupt my outtro! Don't you...
(outro music)